it's obviously an icon
for the mountain
just the symbol of it
you don't have a lot of opportunity in
life these days
to have 10 or 12 minutes
alone
some people think
when they come here and they ride the
chair it's a lonely ride
i never really thought of it that way
mad river was founded by a guy named
roland palmetto because he wanted to
start a ski area where sport and not
money was going to be the overriding
concern he built the single chair here
in 1948
and then someone figured out very
quickly that a double chair was just as
easy to build as a single chair the
single chairs went away very quickly and
this thing has kind of hung around for a
long time
you're forced to really focus on what's
going on around you to look down just
watch some of the skiers having fun and
when you get up there you can look
across the valley into new york
as the ski industry has changed over the
years this place hasn't everything that
we do
shouldn't work but it does
there's not a lot of ski areas in the
world where
the skiers are donating money to build a
lift
there's something about like you know
waiting in line in the corral and you're
going back and forth
and you're saying hi to people you're
carrying on multiple conversations
it's just a real friendly vibe
that you know it's not like a hashtag
campaign where we're trying to
create a community it's already here
sitting on that single chair
is like coming home
you